we all in the national media are waiting
here Mike Zimmer say he's my guy
period end of story are you you know I
I'll be honest man I don't catch Coach
Zimmer's press conferences I don't I
don't I don't watch a lot of NFL Network
or any of that stuff now second case but
okay okay good keep going what you're
saying go for it oh just just saying
that a lot of that stuff man there's
there's a lot of people's opinion out
there I'm not saying coach Zimmer's
opinion don't matter I'm saying like you
know the media and what happens there
you know a lot of that stuff is just
kind of white noise to me you know I
come in I trust what my coaches say and
and and coach me up to do and you know
when it comes down to it I want to I
want this football team to win and that
you know that doesn't matter you know
what what my role is what they say my
role is whatever it is I'm gonna come in
and be the best whatever it is they want
me to be I'm gonna come in and be the
best that I can be but the the
conversation by the way is that if you
don't keep doing what you're doing then
Teddy Bridgewater standing right there
and he's the guy that was drafted he was
the guy who they went to the playoffs
whether your team did before you were
there and thus that's the guy for the
future you're not you're not looking
over your shoulder as you play football
okay no I'm not looking over my shoulder
I know every every time I go out there
you got to prove yourself I mean every
every time you do a podcast rich you got
a you gotta prove yourself but there's
I'm sure there's a hundred people out
there behind you that you know that
wants your job to I mean are you looking
over your shoulder well I look over my
shoulder I see my show name you know
what I mean like I see it right there
you know I mean I'm feeling it people
out there know you want your job yes and
you know they they're doing everything
they can to to do that too and so for me
I know that there's a there's a lot of
people that you know want to be one of
the 32 so I don't take it lightly
you know I don't dwell on that I don't
think that makes me a better football
player by looking over my shoulder so I
just work on doing what I can do and and
being the best that I can be and you
know letting all that stuff you know
work work itself out okay well case just
just know that's you're speaking to a
member of the media who's very you know
we're all very thin-skinned we have egos
you just you know don't don't say you
don't watch I got it on I got it on DVR
okay and I go through and I watch I
watch every every episode in the off
season in the off season okay all right
so the day after you pick the confetti
out of your hair
in your home stadium is what you're
saying it's not what I'll be and I'll be
calling you and talking about how you're
doing and and asking me whether I had a
good enough broadcast to keep doing my
job that's what yes and then what were
you thinking taking that call from that
dude and what were you thinking on that
one I don't quite like the tables being
turned on me I understand thanks case
appreciate you calling
thank you bet that's case Kim at Case
Keenum 7 how about that well table
turning not a big fan of I hate look but
let's you need to add attitude that's
pretty good need that attitude he's
bawling out man there's not a window he
doesn't think he could fit it in and he
is dropping dimes and he is finding guys
like Thielen and Diggs could you imagine
if Dalvin cook didn't get hurt yeah he
would be doing stuff what camara is
doing right now there's no reason to
think that he couldn't he was so good
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience